[Musik]
sie gilt als kinderstube der kegel raum
ich besuche die insel helgoland wo jedes
jahr hunderte jungtiere geboren und
aufgezogen werden
[Musik]
es gibt in der tat nur wenige orte an
denen man den kegelrobben so nah kommen
können wie hier auf helgoland und diesen
wirklich viel süßer als gedacht hätte
aber auch viel gefährlicher
ich bin gut zwei stunden mit der fähre
unterwegs bevor ich deutschlands einzige
hochseeinsel erreiche helgoland galt
einst als seeräuber nest bevor es im
neunzehnten jahrhundert zum beliebten
urlaubsziel wurde
doch ich bin nicht angereist um die
roten klippen mit der berühmten langen
anna zu besichtigen
mich zieht es zur baden bühne wie die
einheimischen die vorgelagerte insel
nennen im winter kommen weniger besucher
dafür aber umso mehr kegelrobben und
ihretwegen bin ich hier
manchmal sind es so viele tiere das
ranger in gute pausch den strand
zeitweise sperren muss um den robben
etwas ruhe
vor allem aber den menschen den nötigen
schutz zu bieten denn was hier so süß
aussieht ist das größte in deutschland
frei lebenden raubtiere
wir nehmen den eigens dafür angelegten
dünnen pfad von hier aus können wir
ungestört beobachten warum die tiere
eigentlich da sind von november bis
januar ist wurf und paarungszeit als wo
vielleicht ist es so attraktiv weil das
sturmflut sicher ist und das ist ganz
ganz wichtig für die auswahl eines
golfplatzes die junge kegelrobben sind
ja erst mal darauf angewiesen dass sie
mindestens drei bis vier wochen an land
liegen können
und das zählt
aus nächster nähe kann ich verfolgen wie
die jungtiere gesorgt werden
nach zwei bis drei wochen lässt die
coole junge ist allein dann sind die
kegelrobben auf sich gestellt
[Musik]
obwohl sie alle relativ gleich aussehen
gibt ängstliche gibt es ja welche die
gleich auf krawall gebürstet sind die
immer unfreundlich sind es gibt welche
die gucken sich alles in ruhe an also
vollkommen unterschiedliche charaktere
nach einigen wochen unternehmen die
jungen robben ihre ersten
schwimmversuche aber erst nachdem sie
ihr erstes fell abgelegt haben das weiße
so kuschelig aussehende logo bietet im
wasser nicht genügend schutz mehr als
650 jungtiere sind diesen winter hier
zur welt gekommen so viele wie noch nie
schon zwei wochen nach der geburt sind
die weibchen wieder paarungsbereit
die bullen sind zu der zeit besonders
aggressiv die bis zu 300 kilogramm
schweren tiere kämpfen um die gunst der
weibchen
all das kann ich hier beobachten direkt
am strand fühle ich mich einer seite von
ute bautsch sicherer auf jeden fall
gerade dabei ein jungtier zu begatten zu
wollen
die wirken niedlich aber sie sind das
nicht
jetzt weiß ich auch warum man 30 meter
abstand halten soll
also ich würde sagen so beiden von
unserer sorte kann da einfach durch
gewissen ehrlich
nach der aufzucht und paarungszeit
verlassen die robben nach und nach die
insel und sind nur noch vereinzelt zu
sehen
bis zum nächsten winter so viele
kegelrobben hier in der freien natur zu
erleben ist wirklich beeindrucken vor
allem die kleinen wenig diesen wirklich
wirklich so ist aber darin so nah kommen
merkt man das ist in der tat super
gefährliche raubtiere sind und deswegen
schaue ich mir die lieber aus sicherer
entfernung an
da ich auf das streicheln aber nicht
verzichten will habe ich mir von meinen
töchtern ein echtes kuscheltier
ausgeliehen
[Musik]